so my name is Saker takunda and i
I guess this is session three we have
two speakers our first speaker is the
Andros two Surrealists in the blue a
little bit about him he's a professor in
the Department of Electrical Engineering
at Yale and his research interests
include computer and communication
networks with an emphasis on developing
models and algorithms for complex
networks architectures and protocols for
wireless systems as well as exploring
sensor networks and novel internet
architectures in addition he has a
rather vast experimental platform for
conducting his research Leandra's joined
Yale about four weeks ago so he's brand
new and I think he's still unpacking
boxes so welcome our next speaker is a
Peter hunt he's a professor of economics
at the Yale School of Management
he's a research associate at the
National Bureau of Economic Research and
a specialist warned status researcher at
the US Census Bureau and his research
focuses on how countries firms and
workers respond to globalization
he joined Yale in 1999 so I'm guessing
most of his boxes are unpacked by now so
so welcome Leandra thank you thank you
Shekhar hi everybody I'm glad to be here
and have the opportunity to give this
talk the flavor of my talk will be a bit
different than what we have here done
till now our research is focused on
communication networks that is on how to
manage the transport of data from where
they are generated to the users and
present a few problems related to
current challenges for mobile networking
and how to address them so I will start
with some background and motivation of
what you hear and the motivation is the
explosion of mobile data the last few
years and the diagram here
or that and as we see the main reason
for the data the mobile data explosion
is essentially the smartphones and all
the videos that either streamed to the
mobile user or they are recorded and
uploaded by the user so this is some
current data the 2012 13 and 14 and some
projected numbers for the data growth as
they are predicted by a study performed
by Cisco so we see that there is an
average annual growth of 66% and as
we'll see in the next slide that is much
faster than the mobile network capacity
is growing the capacity of mobile
network is growing by various actions of
the operators first there is some
increase on the available licensed
bandwidth then there is a continuous
additional deployment of new cell sites
and there are improvements of the
wireless technology itself that allows
to push more bits per Hertz
now all this adds up to an average
annual growth that is of the order of
29% that is far behind than the increase
in mobile data so that stresses the
mobile operators quite a bit and they
are look they looked all kind of
alternatives to deal with this explosion
of course there are developments on the
wireless technology itself currently we
are using 4G networks Bay
Stone vld technology and there is
underway research for the next
generation of mobile wireless technology
what is called the 5g technology but
this will take a while it's a technology
that will be based on the 60 gigahertz
band and will provide a very significant
increase of the capacity but until then
and this will take a few years at least
there is an urgent need to deal with the
increasing demand for capacity and I'll
present three approaches we have
considered recently for dealing with
this problem and the first one is what
we call data offloading what we mean by
data floating typically mobile services
are provided by cellular base stations
owned by the mobile operators that
operate in the license spectrum which is
licensed to the different operators now
in addition to roles there is a
proliferation of other means for
wireless access more specifically the
Wi-Fi access points which are
omnipresent nowadays and they can be of
three kinds the residential access
points owned by dividuals
enterprise access points as well as
access points deployed by different kind
of operators which are provided for
service to the users now this access
points operate in an unlicensed spectrum
band and they are much cheaper in many
ways than wireless access through the
license spectrum to the cellular
operator websites so one approach
for dealing with increase in the
capacity is to try to use to use to the
extent possible this other means for
wireless access that is access points
and femtocells and offload a bit the
cellular base stations
now this offloading is happening in many
ways for instance the mobile operator
themselves deploy their own access point
networks and perhaps you have seen some
of it already moving around for instance
AT&T has deployed 32,000 Wi-Fi hotspots
that is 32,000 access points primarily
in heavy traffic areas in addition there
are other companies like phone we have
their own deployed the access point
network now besides those the vast
majority of access point we see they are
residential access points or enterprise
access point owned by individual
entities and the big opportunity will be
if there is an effective way to exploit
the available capacity of those access
points for offloading what we mean if
you turn on your Wi-Fi interface of your
smartphone wherever you are you will see
typically at least a thousand it doesn't
or more networks are available but they
are all locked because they belong to
individuals if there is a way to make
them available somehow to you and have
the mobile operate or save the capacity
by directing you to those access points
instead of serving you directly that
will be a big game for them
and we studied some ways to do that and
we came up with a method that
essentially views this interaction of
the access points and the different
mobile operator operator says a market
where the operators try to buy in some
sense services by the access points and
the access points try to benefit somehow
by the fact that they offer their
capacity to the operators to redirect
the traffic so in a typical scenario we
may have a number of cell site and deniz
belonging to different mobile operators
and they operate in the same area with a
number of access points its access point
belonging to different individuals
now it's sell-side from a technical
point of view may redirect their mobile
users to a number of access points who
are within reach and at the same time
its access point may provide this kind
of service to different cell sites in
the sense that it may serve mobile users
from different operators and the
question is what is an effective way of
assigning access points to mobile
operators effective from two points of
view one point of view is to do the
optimal allocation of mobile users to
access points and offload let's say cell
sides which are heavily utilized and
they are incapacity and they cannot
serve adequately the
users and at the same time satisfy other
efficiency indicators like for instance
try to upload mobile users which are at
the periphery of the cell of cellular
operator because those users are most
costly in serving them both in terms of
consume bandwidth and energy now at the
same time access points we should have
some incentives for providing the access
capacity even though it is free for them
the fact that they're providing should
give back some benefits so this
incentives should be somehow
proportional to the benefit they will
offer to the mobile operators and the
best way to do that is to create a
market now it turned out that some more
traditional ways for doing that like
different types of functions like the
visit the auction or the McAfee auction
are not efficient for that particular
case because they will require in
general an intermediate broker that may
need to invest in the market that is to
put money or some kind of utility in the
market and the best way to do that was
to use a double auction which is an
extension of a Kayle mechanism for the
network utility maximization so we came
up with a setting for this double
auction where both the mobile network
operators and the access points are used
as are viewed as bidders and they bid
based on the price on some prices
offered by an intermediate broker now it
turned out that the scheme was effective
oops I'll skip this in the sense
it is amenable to a distributed
implementation through an intermediate
broker that emits let's say scalar
signals and allows an iterative exchange
of beads between the participating
bidders and it turned out that it
converges to some allocation of access
points to cell sites which is socially
optimal socially optimal with respect to
the utility factions which are selected
now by a careful selection of the
utility function both from the side of
the mobile network operator in the
access point this double action
mechanism may converge to different
let's say equilibrium points and the
challenge for the designer is to select
those utility functions appropriately
now I'll skip to this kept us busy the
last couple of years as you see for the
related publications I'll skip to the
second setting just to give you a flavor
I'll skip a few if you fly a few slides
I will just would like to let you know
that in a week time in Oklahoma rate
I'll give the same presentation the full
version one out of eight in the in
seminar so if you got interested from
what you hear today you are welcome on
October 8 in the in seminar so a second
problem we consider it is what is called
the user-provided Network and it is we
try to address the same challenge from
but from a different way that is instead
of living the game of capacity to the
cellular operators
that try to capture access points we
view the mobile user itself as a
potential network provider that is the
smartphone that the user carries may act
both as a gateway to the Internet as
well as a relay to the user and by
having the users assume those three
different roles that is consumers of
service or relay or gateway in an
appropriate way
they may provide the service to each
other without with being transparent to
the network and the question is how to
do this effectively by mimicking schemes
that have been adopted in other domains
for a similar purpose for instance the
Airbnb is an example right of a similar
type of interaction but in a different
domain now some reason advantages in
networking like the software-defined
networks which are available today I
provide all the technical flexibility
for adopting such schemes and
implementing them let me give you some
examples of how such scheme will work
and what are the challenges here for
instance we see three smartphone
carriers in the first picture that may
act either as consumer service which is
the client here or as intermediates for
providing connection to the Internet so
the two smartphones which are labeled
gateways they
a direct connection to the Internet one
through a cellular connection and the
other through a Wi-Fi connection and the
third user benefits from their own
internet connection to have to have his
own internet connectivity through them
in the second picture we have a to hope
sad scheme where the client smartphone
accesses the internet through a to hope
connection to the smartphone that has a
direct access to the Internet through
through his cell connection and in the
other two pictures we see two other
scenarios of such role exchange between
relay and the gateway which have some F
which have which provide the eventual
internet connectivity to the final
client now as a network of wolves and
the smartphones move around their
connections their direct connections to
the internet change both in terms of
availability or quality so different
potential scenarios of clients relays
and gateways become possible and the
question is which scenario will be
adopted its time such that the Internet
connectivity is efficient in terms of
speed and energy consumption and it's
also fair fair in the sense that its
user take its turn serving the other
user and we don't end up in schemes
where some users always act as gateways
providing both capacity and energy for
Internet connectivity while other users
always been
it by having Internet connectivity as
clients without spending money from
their own cellular connection or energy
and we came up with a scheme to do that
I will just mention some highlights of
the scheme first the scheme is based on
the nos bargaining solution as the
underlying conceptual framework for
exchange of services it employs some
virtual currency to deal with to deal
with the problem that different times
instances time instances different users
have different quality of internet
connections and they probably can
provide service or obtain service and
furthermore nas but gaining solution in
that particular case naturally provides
a distributed means for implementing it
and keeping track of which users have
benefit for how much time and how much
its user owes to the other for the
future so it turned out that this scheme
works well and and it turns out that it
fits well with a very recent framework
that is available by open garden which
provides a technology for doing that and
the credit scheme we proposed it can be
adopted by the open garden framework for
regulating the user access so I'll take
the stiff
minutes to say a few words about the
third problem which again tries to
address the same challenge from a
different viewpoint
now the viewpoint is the following again
we need to deal with the rapid capacity
demand the increase of the capacity
demand and this is a problem that is
faced by the mobile operator itself that
is the mobile operator or in its effort
to increase the infrastructure capacity
it deploys cell sides of different
nature that is some some large cells
some are micro cells or Pico cells in
the sense of the cells with periphery of
a few 10 meters but this requires an
excessive infrastructure for connecting
all those cells to the internet and a
problem then is that a bottleneck is
created on how all these cells will be
connected to the wired infrastructure so
a method to deal with this ball a
bottleneck is again an implicit one that
takes advantage of the fact that a lot
of traffic nowadays especially the
downlink traffic from the network to the
user is repetitive that is a large
number of users are seeing the same
video or a large number of users in the
same location access the same data so a
natural way to deal with it is to add
storage at different stages of the
network and in particularly close to the
base station selves so a novel
mobile network architectures have
storage at all these different levels
and the challenges
to effectively use the storage that is
what traffic we should store at each
particular storage gas that is available
at different parts of the network now in
order to evaluate this there is a number
of considerations one is the likelihood
that a certain piece of information will
be needed at a particular point of the
network and this can be predicted to a
large extent by considering the social
network structure of the mobile users
that is the characteristics of the
access characteristics of the friends
let's say of a specific user another
consideration is the service cost of the
different connections that these certain
links are more expensive than others and
I would like to use those as little as
possible and that somehow influences the
kind of data that will store in the
caches that offload those links and
another consideration is the service
policy itself that is we need to give a
priority I mean certain types of data
have priority over the others and those
should be given priority in storage in
the local caches as well
so all these considerations should be
taken into account in determining in
determining essentially whether a piece
of data that is delivered to a user will
be kept at the local storage of the base
station at the same time or will be or
will just be neglected so we studied
this problem and we came up with some
some strategy for determining whether a
certain piece of information should be
kept in its gas and the strategy is the
result of the solution of an
optimization problem the challenge was
how to make this strategy simple to
implement such that it is attractive to
a mobile operator since the direct
solution of the optimization problem was
not amenable for an easy implementation
of the mobile operator so we looked in
some approximation methods to the
optimal strategy that made possible an
efficient implementation by the mobile
operator so I think I'll stop here I
just wanted to give you a flavor of the
type of work we are doing and how it is
may be remotely connected to the data
problems the data issues we have seen in
previous talks and I will be available
for any questions you may have later
okay okay thanks for having me here
again I guess a different kind of
presentation this is more about data
that's gonna become available not my own
data but day that's gonna become
available here at Yale through a what's
known as a research data center so I
thought when you use census data every
presentation you do has to have one of
these so I thought even though there's
nothing in it that's using census data I
would put one of these up you have to
put up one of these disclaimers all the
time so I would thought I would take you
very briefly kind of through what RT C's
are what you might get out of them and
why they're about to be a lot easier to
use for jelly's than they were before so
what does an RDC
an RDC is a research data center the US
Census Bureau and increasingly a lot of
other agencies in the US government have
been placing data available for survey
data available for the use by used by
researchers and these data are actually
never leave Sweetland maryland which is
where all the servers are but
increasingly the census is allowing
centers to pop up around the country
which point to those data so research
data center is a physical location
outside of the Census Bureau that allows
one to access census data as well as
census now taking on the role of
archiving data from other agencies and
not just anyone can walk in they're
highly secure locations multiple
passwords and IDs to get in but
researchers who can become qualified
users of the data are allowed access to
these data and the great thing about an
RDC
is they're open 24/7 365 so you with
access you can go in whenever you want
so that's what an RDC is what kinds of
data does an RDC contain so there's a
really broad range of information
available most of the data I'm most
familiar with the data
and the first bullet there and as an
economist using a lot of the economic
data but think of anything you know of
that census collects the people census
business census demographic data lots of
different surveys these data are made
available inside an RDC
at the level at which they're collected
so public datasets might summarize for
example the number of firms that exist
in an industry the economic census if
you access it through an RDC allows you
to see the align the data for every
establishment of every firm that
reported information so tremendous
tremendously useful data for certain
kinds of research and then there's
similar kinds of data available for
demographers for healthcare etc so I'm
not going to go through the data sets
but they're really relatively easy to
find a list of which data sets are
available and kind of the variable is
that they contain actually I should say
they're one of the interesting things
about the census is what's available
publicly and what's not so actually I
think the variable names actually are
not disclosable so one of the funny
things about writing a proposal is you
have to say what data you want to use
without actually having a list of the
variables that are available and the way
you kind of get over that hurdle is you
work closely with administrator of an
RDC who kind of coaches you along about
the data that might be available so for
example if you click on one of these
datasets it wouldn't tell you all the
variables in there it would kind of give
an overview of what information is
contained in that data set so that's
what an RDC is how did yell get an RDC
so the green dots on this map here are
the locations of all of the current
RTC's census began visually there was
just one RTC it was at census around the
time that I was on the job market in
1999 there was the only place pretty
much you could access these data since
then census has been building out this
network you can see it kind of roughly
corresponds to concentrations of
academics around the country and census
is interested in building out this
network even more and an RDC is the main
kind of Center for accessing the data
census as part of its model of expansion
has also been allowing branches to be
established under an existing RDC you
Elle has been a member since 2006 of the
consortium that founded the New York
research data center
Princeton's in that Columbia is in that
the Fed is in that that's located in
Butte College so currently I go down to
New York once a week to use the data
there we applied successfully to become
a branch of the New York RDC in New
Haven there's another branch of the New
York RDC in Cornell and with generous
funding from Kohl's we're gonna have
this branch our DC show up on Hill House
and one of the econ Department buildings
it's the cost is about two hundred
dollars to set up this branch that's
mostly due to the costs within Yale of
making the space secure and then about
fifty thousand chunk of it is IT
equipment that we get from Yale servers
I mean dumb terminals that kind of point
back to Washington the floor plan how
would you do for time but the thing is
the center looks like this the top of it
is an office for the administrator that
has to oversee the branch and then that
bigger room is a space with six
terminals six terminals depending on
whether you've done stuff like this
before may seem like a lot or a little
the New York office has eight terminals
and I go down there a bomb was never
seen it full we're hoping that six will
be a pretty good number but we'll see
how that goes the key thing to realize
if you don't really know it is that
since yell is a member of an RTC
consortium anyone at Yale actually can
access the data for free given that
we're ready paying the dues for that and
that'll be true for the branch as well
so really the only cost for the user is
to kind of get a proposal approved by
the Census Bureau by the way I wanted to
put this slide in we need an
administrator and so if you have any
ideas around the room please let me know
or Sandra Grier know our administrator
the the administrator of a typical RDC
is a relatively senior fellow usually
it's a PhD than one in New York is a PhD
in economics for example we only need a
junior administrator someone working 20
hours a week the hitch is that that
person who is the administrator has to
be an inset a census employee they're
not
a Yale employee and so the way this
works is we're looking around campus for
someone that might be interested in this
job it's 20 hours a week it's very
flexible most the time you don't have to
do much and the way to work is we'll
identify a candidate hopefully within
the next month or two and then we
specify the parameters that individual
and give those parameters to Census and
then census hires that person after a
search for that individual and then that
person becomes a regular census employee
and is on an employee track within
census so any ideas would be very
welcome so that's my little pitch for a
administrator okay now you know what an
RDC is how can you get access to an RDC
as I said these are proprietary data
they're governed by a whole host of laws
which if you get access you have to
learn about the laws and all the ways
you can be punished by violating them so
I won't bore you with all those details
but it's restricted by law and one of
the things that you may not be that
familiar with but which is an integral
part of getting access to census data is
your your research proposal not only has
to have the usual intellectual merit the
census proposed the proposed research
also has to have a benefit for census
and the reason for that is by law census
can only kind of provide access to these
data if they're in a part of an effort
to improve the quality of the data at
census and so when one writes in a
proposal for research at the Census
Bureau a big part of what you write in
your well a big in terms of importance
not so big in terms of words part of the
proposal that you write is how you're
going to benefit the Census Bureau and
they have these great quotes on their
website about this and they're they're
quite I mean listening to the
presentations today they should sound
very familiar you know census collects
all of this information and one of the
best ways to figure out if the
information is correct and makes sense
is to give it to users and see what they
find and if you have proposed research
we'll be using the data and in part
checking the quality data because of all
the things that you're looking for and
so they take that that's taken pretty
seriously and I should say it's not that
hard to come up with ways to
improve census data to put into proposal
and again when one develops proposal in
conjunction with the administrator of an
RDC they guide you along in terms of how
to word this okay and then then there's
the normal the rest of the bullet points
they are the normal criteria another
consideration is again I said the major
cost of getting involved with census
data is actually getting the access and
this varies the time it takes from kind
of deciding you want to start working on
a proposal to getting the oppose Allah
proved and then getting your security
clearance for using the data which isn't
that onerous but is a step it takes
about a year that that can sometimes get
longer that sometimes gets shorter
depending upon staffing and how things
are going in DC and whether there's a
budget crisis etc but think about a year
half a year to a year to get access if
you want more information I put these up
I felt more information just Google
Center for economic studies Census
Bureau and you'll get all these websites
they'll describe all of these data sets
okay
that's mostly what I was going to go
through I have appendix slides to know
more but I figured I would leave that
for questions either in this forum or
you can come up afterwards or send me an
email or something and I'm happy to give
you more info Thanks
thank you
excuse me do you provide access to high
performance computing form of Yale at
the same time on the same sessions to
use I mean for analytics to run
application to execute different
analytics do you have do provide access
to high performance computing on the
same sessions in order not to copy data
or such a thing all of the IT
infrastructure is provided at Census and
so they have a server network and all
the software that is most often used you
know Stata MATLAB whatever I wouldn't
characterize as a high-speed computing
network and there's no way to kind of
take the data from where they are so you
know you're kind of using the the IT
infrastructure that they have and you're
actually using it on the networks that
are holding the console what sort of you
know high performance computing farm do
they provide this sensors yeah I'm not
sure about the technical details it's
kind of I think a standard UNIX type
setup it's not one that's hyper you know
like the high speed clusters that we
caused not like that
I mean they could always add that I
think if there were enough demand to do
that they would add it right now it
seems to be pretty radical I mean given
I've been doing research there for like
10 years it seems pretty adequate for
the demands that I've had okay thank you
follow-up question how big is this data
okay so there are five everything says I
know there are five and a half million
private establishments in the United
States so one of the data one of the
data sets the LBD which tracks all
private stash the United States has
about five million observations you know
and then a whole bunch of fields for
that observation across years go back to
1977 so data sets range the days that I
work with about a gigabyte or so when
you put things together
no problem kind of manipulating those
data sets I think you can't always do
that for example in one statistical
package but you could also move to SAS
or something if it gets on ERISA so it's
that kind of follow up so you mentioned
that yeah they provide this AHRQ data
which is H cup data for probably all of
these states and just for one a state
California escape data that I'm working
with yeah one of the three databases
gets like seven gigabytes for just four
years five years so for the entire
United says it should be like more than
100 gigabytes or 300 kilo I say I don't
know but so I've seen people running
jobs where they for example to the
extent that I can see the memory being
pulled it's like 150 200 gigabytes that
they're using for those projects they
run those projects I'm still doing my
project which is smaller and it seems to
work fine I mean I've never used that
stuff so maybe those you know they're
researchers at Yale who are using those
data said I think in public health I'm
not sure where you are and so they might
know better for example what the what
that experience is like when they put
all those things in one file or try to
manipulate them Center for outcome
research and evaluation and we obtain
data by directly from a
hrq organization so I don't know much
about the medical data but I I mean so I
don't I can't characterize what's there
and I can't characterize a user
experience but I could find out more
point you to where to find out more if
you need to thank you yeah sure
I have a quick question about the
restricted data and what you can what
you can do with it if anything outside
the terminals that you were talking
about so does all the analysis happen at
the terminals or is there a certain
point in the process of analyzing the
data where it is anonymized enough that
you can you know take it on a flash
drive and do your own work with it so
the way it works is anything that
they've figured out how to anonymize
they usually make into some kind of
public use data set the way it works is
all your analysis which is not
anonymized you can work with at the
census and then you have to any results
of that analysis that you want to take
out but not the data you can't take the
data out have to pass disclosure the
rules for disclosure themselves are not
disclosable so but to give you a sense
of you know if I run regressions of how
firms have reacted to something
you basically have to not be able to in
any way identify a single firm so if
you're doing the kind of high level
stuff that I do it's never really an
issue the users that run into issues or
if you want to kind of summarize things
happening at the census block level or
something where there might be like a
few people living there that's the issue
so the basic rule is you do your
analysis there and then you present
results in an aggregate enough way that
you can pass disclosure so regressions
and regression coefficients are usually
fine
that goes you hand those in along with
the disclosure report and the analysis
of light doesn't violate disclosure it
goes to a disclosure review board they
bless it or they don't if they bless it
they send you the stuff and then think
of that as getting a bunch of regression
tables in the mail like an Excel or
something like that an email okay
hey so Leandro's I have a question for
you
about uh so you're in the Department of
Electrical Engineering but you're a ins
affiliate and what we understand yen's
is doing what we've heard presentations
last year at the day of data was a lot
about human social networks so how do
the sensor networks that you're talking
about sort of relate to that is it
really transferable like the network of
a sensor is the same as the network of a
person or are you going to be working
more on human social networks too so
what are you gonna do it in I think it
happens in many levels first at the
abstract levels of the models the
network models for the interaction of
humans in social networks and the
network models for interaction let's say
of wireless devices have a lot of common
aspects for instance the questions of
how the scale and what are the
attributes that affect the scaling are
answered by the same mathematics
essentially show the the abstract models
are similar the other is that there is a
lot of interaction between the two in
the real world as well
for instance current trend in wireless
networks that is cognitive radio as it
is called which is which tries to find
very effective ways for using the radio
spectrum taking in the most duration in
the dependencies between the different
devices can exploit a lot of input that
is generated from the social network
that is relationships of people as they
can be did use from the social network
they they can provide information on how
likely it is
one to try to access the radio spectrum
at the same time with somebody else and
this is information that is very useful
for the design of the radio access
protocol itself so this is just two
examples of how the two are related and
not only those two for instance the
presentation we have seen earlier by
mark Gerstein pointed to some other
attributes which relate the networks
that appear in genomic in the genomes
with the network the networking
structures that the capture either the
social networks or the communication
networks so I think that's a main idea
for the creation of the Institute is to
focus on these commonalities and take
advantage of those to progress all these
different fields and we will reconvene
promptly at 4:05 thank you to professor
shot and Tess Lewis who gave our last
session